tiktok with its viral dance routines and
political activism videos
is a favorite among teenagers worldwide
with over 2 billion downloads and 17
billion dollars in revenue last year
the app is extremely successful and
influential
but its exploding popularity has also
raised red flags
in the u.s officials are investigating
whether tick-tock is a threat to
national security
there are concerns that the data
collected by the app owned by the
chinese firm bite dance
could be accessed by beijing the company
denies any connection with the chinese
government
but donald trump is threatening to ban
the app in the u.s
we're looking at tick-tock we may be
banning tick-tock we may be doing
some other things or a couple of options
but a lot of things are happening so
we'll see what happens but
we are looking at a lot of alternatives
with respect to tick-tock
reports on friday indicated that one of
the alternatives being considered
is an order for bite dance to give up
ownership of tick tock
potential buyers are reportedly already
in talks to take over the app's u.s
operations including tech giant
microsoft
a national security review of tick tock
is expected to be presented to trump in
the coming days
its results may further sour already
deteriorating ties between the u.s and
china
with tensions already running high on
trade and the coronavirus pandemic
cyber security concerns are now further
straining relations between the two
powers
now let's bring in our business
correspondent jens corte in new york
so what power does trump actually have
to put pressure on a chinese company
like that
well i mean u.s president donald trump
probably could not directly order
um tick tock or um the mother company
to sell the u.s assets or operations
for example but as we heard he could say
okay we're going
to ban um tick tock and then they could
decide to sell
for example the us operations to
microsoft and then maybe
um u.s president donald trump would uh
or take this uh um order uh
back so um yeah that's probably um how
the whole
deal could work and what is behind the
american government's mistrust of this
app
tick tock
well i mean they have charges for quite
some time that
tick tock is actually collecting
um privacy data from its users so we
have those some
accusations those charges by the way not
just in the united states but um
also um in the uk or in um germany a
tick tock himself
always was saying that well for example
with the u.s operations all the servers
are
also us-based but still there were some
suspicions
that even if the servers are in the u.s
that does not necessarily mean that data
has not been transferred to beijing
and looking at the business aspect of
things here
we've heard reports that microsoft might
be trying to buy
the the us shares of tick tock would
this be a good deal for microsoft
well i mean tick tock is incredibly
successful within a
very short time span they just recently
surpassed two billion uh downloads of
the tick top
edge worldwide as far as we know there
are estimates that tick tock the
entire operation might be worth about 50
billion dollars so only the u.s
operations would go for less and that is
money
that microsoft could clearly
afford but on the other side then
microsoft also might be
right in between those two struggling
super powers
the united states and china so we will
wait and see
if microsoft is really following that
path
dw business correspondent jens corte in
new york thank you
three people have been charged in
connection with the hacking of prominent
twitter accounts two weeks ago
prosecutors say a 17 year old from
florida and the u.s
was the master mastermind behind the
hack that duped people into making
bitcoin donations
it affected some of the platform's most
high profile accounts
including former u.s president barack
obama democratic presidential candidate
joe biden
microsoft founder bill gates as well as
some companies accounts like
apple and uber twitter said the hackers
targeted some of its employees who had
access
to its internal systems